We have to figure out a way I think as educators...
...to harness the power of these technologies,...
...which children have a natural attraction to.
Figure out a way that they can be used as learning devices,...
...which is really what they are after all.
And we're working at Sesame Street...
...to try to use all kinds of technologies including mobile phones...
...to teach the alphabet...
...and maybe in developing countries even leapfrog over a lot of the inadequacies in formal schooling.
Well, the role of the teacher will inevitably change...
...maybe a little more of a mentor,...
...a little more of a coach.
A guide, someone who can edit the endless amounts of information...
...that is available now to all of us on the web.
Figure out a way to point children towards answers without giving them the answers...
...so that they can really build problem solving skills...
...which is a huge part I think of any successful education program in the world.
So technology and the teachers will find a different way I think to interact with each other.